Henry cavill's fans have a lot to say
about his haircut in the upcoming Argyle
and they're not holding back from
cartoon character comparisons to
downright meanness here's what people
are saying about the actor's New Look
whether it's hunting monsters as geralt
of Rivia or saving the day as Superman
there's little Henry Cavill can't
pretend to do and his fans usually love
seeing the actor no matter the project
naturally his upcoming appearance in
Matthew Vaughn's Argyle has fans talking
but not quite in the way commonly
associated with the actor's work Capital
plays Argyle a super spy and the main
character of fictional author Ellie
Conway's novel of the same name
following the trailer's Premiere the
conversation didn't take long to shift
to cavill's spy Thriller hairstyle a
questionable flat top that's incredibly
uncharacteristic of the actor's usual
looks on X formerly known as Twitter one
user applied to images of cabell's
character asking is it only me that
doesn't like the haircut it's not every
day that Cabell finds himself on the end
of countless roasts but fans have
flooded x with jokes about his hairstyle
in Argyle for example one fan posted an
image of cattle's character writing dear
God somebody needs to CGI that hair
while the actor infamously had his
mustache removed for Justice League the
user believes Argyle could make up for
that mistake by using visual effects to
improve his hairstyle in the film The
New Look is so jarring that another
shocked user didn't even recognize
Cavill others compared cavill's movie
hairstyle to other fictional characters
specifically characters whose hairstyles
nobody would want to have in the real
world One X User wrote he looks like a
street fighter antagonist another
shocked fan said on the site Roe went to
The Barbers and said can I have the Duke
Nukem please did you think I was gone
forever other users compared Cavill to
Captain Planet Johnny Bravo even Arnold
Schwarzenegger's character in red heat
on the bright side one user had more
positive things to say about cavil's
haircut right I love how he is so
committed with his character that he
accepted to look like this even being
one of the most beautiful men on Earth
either way it's clear that while the
movie tries to entice audiences with the
tagline from the Twisted mind of Matthew
Vaughn the most Twisted thing an Argyle
could be cavill's haircut that said it's
difficult to deny just how much of the
conversation surrounding Argyle is
focused on cavill's unique look while
the flat top has certainly proven to be
controversial it's also important to
point out that fans of the British actor
don't always respond negatively when he
switches up his look after all the actor
received considerable praise for rocking
the handlebar mustache in 2018's Mission
Impossible Fallout in the Tom Cruise
action thriller Cabell stepped into the
shoes of the nefarious August Walker a
rogue agent who goes toe-to-toe with
cruises Ethan Hunt while speaking with
Entertainment Weekly kavel candidly
discussed just how strange but cool it
was to sport the big mustache Cavill
told the outlet if I was ever going to
grow a mustache it would have to be a
world-changing mustache and I'm glad it
was Cabell went on to add that he
learned to love his mustache and it
turns out that many of his fans loved
that look too on X fans can still be
found reminiscing over cavill's iconic
mustache era earlier this year one fan
wrote on the site watching Mission
Impossible Fallout Henry Cavill is
really good in it and he looks fantastic
with a mustache meanwhile back in 2021
another ex-user had this to say to be
fair to Paramount I too see why they
wouldn't allow Henry Cavill to shave his
mustache you could start a religion
around this thing the user is of course
referring to Paramount Pictures not
allowing Cowell to remove his stash for
Justice League reshoots however the
consensus is clear fans are totally open
to caval switching up his looks so long
as they're actually good looks while it
remains to be seen how Argyle fares it's
all but certain that the flick won't be
able to totally Escape his character's
haircut cut
[Music]